ice. Eat a you fat pigs. You pieces of [__] I hope
you die. You're not Gestapo. I hope you yourself. I hope you
suck start your [__] the second you get >> I
don't think they can apply force to them or detain them at all.
>> So I, Officer McDouchebag, was doing an ICE operation
harassing random Hispanic people in the city of Minnesota and
two white Karens walked up to my car and told me that I was a
piece of and I got off. As a result, knowing that I could use
18 USC11 as a pretext, I approached said women in an attempt
to with them in order to get them to stop with me. When they
picked me off, I knew that I could use 18 USC 111 as a pretext.
And when I got near to the side of the road, I shoved them in
pepper spray them because these people for trying to [__]
with me.
We'll do um let's go to the Pisco combo with Connor. That's better.
We'll do ice stuff instead. Connor and Pisco had a conversation
about the ice shooting this morning. It was interesting. Pisco
watches the full thing over here on YouTube and then >> agree
that he did not visually see Prey reach for a gun.
>> Do you agree that he is in a position such that he is
in line of sight of the gun as the officer removes it regardless
of whether or not he perceives it?
>> Do you agree that there's no reason for the officer
believe that this person committed an inherently violent felony?
>> Uh okay. Uh, let me expanded answer, but I can still
give you a clear answer.
>> I would have to look at
obstructing
a law enforcement operation and I would have to see if it's a
misdemeanor or a
>> Why would that make a difference? >> So, so depending
on that, uh, that would be up to the shooting, that's the only
criminal charge that I can think of. >> And, and you don't,
but you don't think that he, uh, just to expound that? There's
no reason that the officer would think that the person like committed
a murder, uh, some sort of aggravated assault, some sort of
>> it would be like simple battery on a law enforcement
officer, which effectively like simple battery for those of you
who don't know, at least within the state of Florida, I could
touch Pisco with a finger and that would be considered simple
battery.
>> And and so just cleaning up and and and um
sort of finishing off. So, you agree he did not visually see
brandishing the gun. Doesn't have a reasonable basis to believe
brandishing for a gun. I did not visually see him reach for a
gun. Um, and
he I I feel like as soon as Connor is bringing those examples
up, don't you feel a little silly that you're talking about like
somebody getting killed? You're like, well, the crime he could
have committed is the equivalent of touching somebody. It's like,
okay,
come on, man. I doesn't this give you like an inkling that you're
headed in the wrong >> appear ever and there's no good
reason to believe he fired a gun. Correct.
>> That's pretty correct. I think he predicated his shots
fired based off of somebody screaming gun. >> Got it. Okay.
And and therefore on that basis you believe it was um objectively
reasonable under the Fourth Amendment.
>> Okay. Your turn.
>> Okay. So,
uh, [laughter]
uh, I I'll try not to be a douchebag and I'll try not to ask
too many questions. >> So, are Ior
CBP agents, federal law enforcement agents, vested with detention
and arrest
even if it's weak.
Can a uh people So, not specifically blasting whistles because
we already read that uh blasting whistles, yelling, all that
kind of stuff is protected by 1A. Okay. But can people obstructing
an officer from being able to go in a certain direction or obstructing
a vehicle from going in a certain direction be contextualized
as disrupting a law enforcement operation? depends what you mean
by some of that.
>> Okay, that that's a sufficient answer for because that's
a gray area that we're going to have to play with later. So,
that's a sufficient answer for me.
>> Um once uh a officer has deemed
that uh the law enforcement operation is being disrupted
um you know, we've already established I think that they have
detention and arrest authority. So, if and perhaps Prey, we'll
get into that.
um if he issues those uh women lawful commands to get out of
the street and get onto the sidewalk and they disobey said commands,
does he have arrest authority over those women? >> Provided
he has reasonable suspicion that a crime was committed or as
part of his investigation uh contingent on reasonable suspicion.
>> Okay. And if the uh the women disobey said lawful orders,
then isn't that in and of itself something that could be considered
like disruptive to the law enforcement operation? >> Depends
what you mean. We'll get into that. Sure. >> Okay. We'll
get into it.
Okay. Now,
uh would uh if I run in the middle of a law enforcement operation,
even if I'm completely morally justified in doing so, okay, I'll
I'll be
If I run into the middle of a law enforcement operation and I
try to separate a law enforcement officer from somebody that
he is taking action on, even if it's morally justified,
can that be construed as a battery on a law enforcement officer
if I touch said law enforcement officer in doing so and try to
separate the parties? >> In my opinion, it depends on the
context. Sometimes yes, sometimes no.
>> Okay. Well, I'm I'm going to tell you that I might press
you on that later. Okay.
um then uh in the escalation of force or response to resistance.
>> I mean, wouldn't that come down to So, he says depend
on the depends on the context. Wouldn't it just be if it's like
a totally unreasonable use of force? Like if you're just watching
a law officer a woman directly and she's like crying and screaming
for help, separating the parties there, while technically you
could maybe argue it's a crime, it's like if the officer is going
to be afterwards, right? Like it's like that doesn't give the
officer the authority to kill somebody. It would have to depend
on what what reasonable expectation or sorry what reasonable
person would a reasonable person would determine is like
I don't what what could be done to separate those two parties.
It it has to be something like that. It can't just be like anytime
touching them is bad. That can't be the case. That would be insane.
>> Uh or whatever you want to call it doctrine. Um are
you aware of the differences between like thresholds like passive
active violent but non-deadly and violent?
Um
um in sorry what's the frame of reference in the continuum of
force? >> So so yes yes it is >> I'm generally aware
of those concepts but there might be some more specific meaning
you're referencing that that might not be uh captured by my understanding
of it. So tenatively I think I do but I don't know >> that
that's a detail we're going to have to get into. So I can't really
phrase an explanation as a question. So I'll just ask you another
question. Um, so do we think that it's been established by case
law in the past that officers can act off of the perceptions
of other law enforcement officers and they themselves do not
have to see what's going on? >> It depends.
So it depends is the answer to that. Yes, there are cases in
which the use of force is justified by virtue of um something
that's being relayed to them. That that's part of the TOC.
Okay. All right, then. Um, I think we I think we could get into
it and however you want to get into it or whatever. Um, I could
narrativize, you could narrativeize, we could pause. >> So,
if you guys aren't familiar, this is obviously the Alex Prey
shooting, the most recent ICE shooting. Um, Pisco has been doing
debates on on the Renee Good shooting as well. I haven't seen
Connor debate on Renee Good, but it seems like Connor is has
he's been tweeting, he's been saying things that indicate support
for the officer who shot Alex Prey, which is pretty crazy to
me. Now, is it neocounter Connor where that's his new Twitter?
I think what he said was it was something was fairly crazy. Hold
on, let me I'll just see if I can find it. Did he stop tweeting
as much? No, he's still tweeting a lot. Um I'll see if I can
>> each other. We could even use that video um as evidence
and pause it chronologically and then debate it chronologically.
Um as a matter of fact, I wouldn't mind doing that only because
the the later violence is >> Yeah. Hold on. This was the
one right here. This is the one that set a lot of people off.
A lot of people were not happy.
Off to go wrestle federal law enforcement with a pistol in my
pants as a as is my second amendment right per Democrats. He's
he tweeted something out a little bit more incendiary than this.
But um but yeah, it's just generally like stuff like this >> predicated
on detention and arrest authority
chronologically
as it unfolds. So, if you want to have a different approach that
you think is going to be faster, we could do your different approach.
If you want to do the video, we could do the video. I don't I
don't care. >> I would appreciate like an open conversation
just initially and then if we feel like we need to go back to
the video, we can definitely do that. I'm not opposed to that
at all. Um >> Okay. Then then if we could still go chronologically,
that would be great. >> Well, I want to start with the
what you want to
um sort of analyze. Do you want to analyze whether or not this
was a use of like an objectively reasonable use of force under
it's like the same thing that we did with Renee Good, right?
Like do you are you interested in the legal
>> I'm interested in both actually because I think that
people would probably be surprised that we probably align morally
and maybe even prescriptively, but we're not going to agree legally.
>> All right. So then why don't we do the throat clearing
legal? That's right. Why don't we give you the space to do the
throat clearing moral stuff cuz I think that we might align on
it and it might be just easier to get out of the way. So, I'll
give you the space now if you want to just throat clear your
thoughts on this. >> Translation Connor, I don't want to
have to hurt you. I don't want my chat to hurt your feelings.
So, could you say some stuff that's going to make them a little
more reasonable with you for the rest of the conversation cuz
if you don't it's going to be >> overall ethical situation
before we get into the justification issue. >> We're not
going to have fun. >> Sure. No, that'd be great. So in
reference to the first amendment um not I believe I'm a republican
in that I actually believe in a republic. Uh I I believe in the
rule of law. I believe in the constitution of the United States.
I think it's a sacrosan docu relatively sacrosan document that
holds us together socially and therefore I want to honor it as
much as possible while still uh giving latitude to the people
who defend it with their lives. And so the first amendment has
held that you know you have the uh freedom of religion, you have
freedom of speech, you have freedom of conscience arguably inferred
from that. You have the right to peaceibly assemble and you have
the right to there was another one
that's relevant but it's peaceibly assemble freedom of speech.
And there was another one that I felt was relevant but I'm not
sure what it is. But anyways, the first amendment covers 100%
in every case law that I've ever seen filming law enforcement
officers in public conducting their duties. There have been states
that have legislated against this and they've been struck down
on first amendment grounds. So, are we in alignment on that moral
analysis that it is perfectly legal and moral to film law enforcement
officers in the conducting of their duties and protest them as
well? >> That's my belief. I'm I'm not sure if the Supreme
Court has squarely held um the direct fact pattern of the sort
of ICE recording stuff going on there, but things that are close
enough. Um, so yeah, and I think that every court, including
a court in the district of
>> I think Pisco is basically just trying to clear up that
possibly if you were like directly obstructing and filming it,
they might say you're not defended to film it and like while
you're in some way obstructing. I think he's trying to create
like um some separation from that. has held that at a bare minimum
recording in the context of where you're allowed to be is protected
by the first amendment as well as sort of being in public streets
again provided that you're you have authorization to be in a
place it's it's a traditional you know public fora things like
that um so yeah I would agree generally with your outlook and
I would also agree that that's the way things ought to be in
a free country >> okay so let's do the second amendment
so uh a wellregulated militia being necessary to the security
of the of a free state the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed um even if this guy didn't have a
concealed weapons permit it would actually not change my calcul
in iota he could have been as long as he wasn't like a hardened
criminal with like you know terrorist offenses in the past or
whatever I actually the you know having a concealed pistol actually
legal or not um I think that as long as he's not a felon basically
he has a right to keep and bear arms and so as a result going
into a dangerous situation regardless of whether or not you perceive
the threat as abusive law enforcement or potentially criminals
that you might bump into he had the right to keep and bear arms
and the the firearm itself
in in isolation does not warrant death >> Okay. I think
you're going to find agreement with a lot of people on that that
uh at least under the current laws peacefully,
you know, within the regulations by the government that have
been approved, um possessing not even just wielding or brandishing
a weapon isn't grounds for death. So, I think that we agree on
that. >> Okay. Um that that's probably where we could start
and I I don't really need to, uh, you know, caveat much more.
I think that what people directionally say is like, "Oh, well,
if you're trying to justify this legally in any sense, then you're
sweeping for the Gestapo Trump
and therefore you hate the First Amendment and the Second Amendment."
Um, I found that line of criticism frustrating and stupid. Uh,
but that's okay. Uh, without >> I respect the fact that
you're like I know that this opinion of yours is going to get
you a lot of flack and I respect you for like sticking your guns,
at least in that limited respect. Um, I don't think that you're
sweeping for Trump or MAGA. I think you're sweeping for cops.
Um, but I don't think that that's because you um are trying to
like institute another like a fourth reich with Trump specifically
or anything like that. I just think that you have a very wrong
and inaccurate and view of uh cop conduct and whether and like
the legal thing. So that's where my focus is mostly and I am
>> if we get >> if we get and we're like not able
to have an adult conversation or whatever um then as a nice little
pallet cleanser I wouldn't mind moving into
>> I think like Connor's
how do you describe it? Connor's
Connor is a former cop kind of mostly all the way. I don't know
what his exact former title was. I know a lot of people meme
about him being a mall cop. I don't know if that's accurate.
Okay. But he um he's he's just very sensitive to cops. And I
think I'm I could maybe like I could sort of let go the defending
of the Renee good thing cuz there is like I think you're really
seeing the world
like a warped view if you think she was trying to kill that guy
or if that guy was like truly scared for his life. I think you're
seeing the world through a warped view. But it's like it's sensible
after you watch like the Alex Pretty guy get like mag dumped
while on the ground not moving.
Right. I feel like after that I'm like, "Okay,
dude. I can't handle you. You can't see the world that it can't
be that warped. If it's that warped, like you have to you're
basically like you get to go in
you you need to be somewhere, okay? You need to get treated >> prescriptions.
Uh because the the abolish ICE thing, you're not going to get
me on. The defund ice thing, you're not going to get me on. However,
there's like tactical things and training things that I think
you would probably agree with. And then therefore, you're not
going to walk away from the conversation being like, "Oh, Conor's
a meattheaded piece of [__] who just loves murdering
innocent people." I could actually give you things that I think
are prescriptive that would help. >> Okay. All right, perfect.
Um, if we need a pallet cleanser, you just give me a timeout.
We'll do a pallet cleanser. Um, and yeah, let's get into the
legal >> I think it's like not even close a case for justified
use of force here. And I basically think that my initial set
of questions to you indicate that really the only ground that
any person could even like facially have to justify this is the
mere fact that someone said gun gun, he has a gun and then you're
qualified as objectively reasonable in those circumstances to
use force in that case throughout the entirety of the use of
force. That is that prolongs as you saw in the video 10 seconds.
And I think that that is so absurd as to be uh essentially um
a free ticket for cops to use that rationale if it were to be
upheld for essentially any situation um in which there could
be loss of life or
>> dude. It's the South Park thing again. OH MY GOD, HE'S
COMING STRAIGHT FOR US. You get whatever animal you want. You
guys ever see that episode of South Park? It's like a very early
one where the uncles are hunting. Stands out hunting with his
uncles. Okay. And every time they see an animal that they're
not allowed to shoot, they go, "OH MY GOD, IT'S COMING STRAIGHT
FOR US." And then they blow that animal. It's the same concept,
right?
It's the exact same concept. OH, GUN, GUN, GUN. THAT'S A BANANA.
OH, IT doesn't matter. I can't do a gun sound effect right now.
Throat's very dry. But you get the you get the picture. Okay.
Just like executing kind of arrest happening. All it would take
is someone saying gun. He has a gun. And Connor would say justified.
And that cannot be objectively reasonable under the circumstances.
And when you add in all the other the totality of circumstance
in this case, to me it is so clear that not only was there not
a qualifying threat, not only was a reasonable officer not think
that there's a qualifying threat, but the use of force persisted
across an unreasonable period of time between two officers that
extends into a situation which he's lying prone face up and six
additional shots have been shot. So I think it's like insane
that you have this take. Also, your some of your characterization
of the facts. He wrestled the cops. he wrestled the cops with
his gun. I don't see evidence of that at all. And so I have to
question I think your conclusion but also your assessment of
the facts.
>> Let's start there because I was explaining that to chat
uh beforehand. But I Okay. So what I'm going to say is 70% of
what you said >> I feel like is jumping ahead of context
that is necessary for TOC and so we need to back up from the
chronology >> made this in 1994. They made it a long time
ago. >> Women confronting the gentleman in the street and
then we'll work our way up to the shooting. However, responding
specifically to the tweet that everybody hated, which is fine,
um, what happened, in my opinion, is that MAGA said, "Oh, he's
a terrorist. He has a pistol. He has three magazines. He was
trying to take out as many officers as possible." And they did
that lame propaganda. Okay? And so, in response, what Josiah
said was, "The gun was legal. This was murder." There's some
tweet in there. I can look for it if I want to, but there's there's
effectively nothing. And I disagree with your and Josiah's characterization
of this as murder. And I think it makes a situation worse. But
that's fine. We we can get into that detail later. >> So
the reason why I posted that, you know, thing, the thrust of
that tweet is not, oh, Mr. Prey is a bad guy who deserved his
death. That's not what I'm >> What I'm arguing is the the
legality of the pistol actually has no bearing
>> No, I agree with
I agree that people are saying that because of the optics of
it. And Conor, you know that. Come on. Like this is to try. It's
>> Oh, I do think
that is probably true, right? In the same way that like regardless
of what the fentanyl levels were in George Floyd's system, like
holding him down like that is probably is still bad, right? It's
like you're you're saying there's some like precondition because
people are saying, "Oh, if it were the opposite, you know, if
it were this other thing, then it would be justified to kill
this guy." But it couldn't possibly be justified to kill this
guy regardless of whatever that condition is. >> It's also
a PR game. And you said it was lame for the individuals to like
of the administration to blatantly lie to our faces in the most
disgusting depraved manner. I think it's totally fair for people
to point to legality of the gun to talk about the entailments
of what someone like your like your view would do to the second
amendment for individuals in that it would trivially make any
such encounter where an officer has bad faith or bad motive to
just say gun to justify turning that into a deadly situation.
And so I don't think there's anything wrong with from an optics
perspective, from a a policy perspect perspective to say, "Hey,
if we adopted your rule, this guy was a legal gun owner. It would
app
that would that rule even apply only to cops
or would that rule apply to like human beings? Could you just
start carrying out like assassinations in public? You just pay
somebody to shout gun." You get into you like bump somebody in
the street and they like get angry at you and then you you've
paid somebody to see that bump that you're going to do on this
GUY TO YELL GUN AND YOU JUST execute this dude in the street.
Luigi was Luigi up in one way. He just forgot this one simple
loophole to get away with murdering as many insurance CEOs as
he wanted. So oh my god, how did he forget? How did he miss >> Well,
more broadly than that. So, I agree that it doesn't specifically
bear on the use of force justification in this case cuz of course
he can't know if it's legally owned at the time he's using the
force and we all know that. But I think that what Josiah is saying
is a like relevant to the optics war which is being waged so
disgracefully by the other side and b relevant to the policy
entailments of your view. And so I don't have any problem with
saying that. Okay. What I would say is that [snorts] uh you guys
are ahead of me uh politically I suppose. Oh, also forgot to
add the extra hour for the five gifted subs on >> angling
uh this conversation in a political direction. What I would say
is while I discuss politics, I have a higher loyalty um and the
loyalty is to the truth as I see it. That that's like my my >> statement
by
hold on hold on. So what I think is going on is that you're saying
that this uh tweet by Josiah that it's murder is pointing to
a deeper hypocrisy with political implications for MAGA who are
saying that he's a terrorist. I'm saying that it's not murder
from my perspective and I'm going to call it out. And what I'm
calling out is the fact that the legality of the firearm actually
has nothing to do with the scenario. And if I inter
>> I mean you could say it's not murder. Here's the problem.
Okay,
there's there's something going on here and this is actually
this is actually a problem that's extremely pervasive in society.
Okay, this idea of like decentralized responsibility because
of the way we communicate because of how you know how big our
population has gotten. You could be pushed in somebody could
be basically be intentfully
by a combination of people without the actual perpetrator of
being like guilty of murder possibly, right? Like it is possible
that that ICE agent was put in that situation where it was likely
he was going to get into like violent confrontations. And maybe
he wasn't thinking I need to kill this guy because I hate him.
Maybe he was thinking like, "Oh, I actually am scared and I am
firing because I'm scared. He's not trained. He doesn't know
what's going on." Right? So it's a form of manslaughter. Maybe
it's not murder, but he was put there intentfully. He was put
there to raise temperature intentionally, right? There's a lot
of things going on where this intent is like decentralized from
him. And so you tell people you you go and tone police people
on the murder thing and that really upsets them because there
was the circumstances were created very intentionally for this
man to die, right? And so
maybe you can tone police on like saying it's murder, that ICE
officer is guilty of murder. Maybe I might even agree that it
might not be murder. I would have to go I'd have to go watch
it again and I'd have to have it slowed down and see like the
different stuff happening like when the gun's taken away. Does
he get any eyes on that? Right. But even if it's manslaughter,
this guy I feel like this guy was murdered. I feel like it's
not wrong to say this guy was murdered.
And
yeah, I don't know. I guess I I'll it'd be interesting to hear
what Connor says the political implications are of saying that
like downstream. Maybe he's saying that, you know, you guys are
hyperbolizing this in a way that MAGA does as well and you're
going down that same track. I I'm guessing that's where he's
going to cook towards, but it's difficult to say. Um I just think
it's interesting. I think it is like it feels minimizing. I don't
know if I I haven't thought about whether or not that, you know,
whatever if Conor's argument were what I was going to say it
is or if his argument is what I just said, then I would have
to think about it more. >> interjected myself. Hold on.
If I interjected myself into any law enforcement operation, I
don't give a if it's by Trump. I don't give a if it's by local
police. I don't give a [__] if it's by county sheriffs.
If I'm a concealed weapon carrier and I interject myself into
a law enforcement operation and I'm carrying a pistol, I am substantially
increasing the risk for all involved including myself. So the
legality of the pistol has no bearing on what unfolded. >> Yeah.
So I think it has a bearing on like I said the broader policy
implications of what you're suggesting in that if it were >> Yeah.
But he doesn't want to clip calling Josiah a liar cuz then he's
got to deal with that. So >> for the case that yours insanely
low deadly force standard were found to be objectively reasonable,
it would bear on and would chill people's willingness to openly
carry. That's how it's relevant to the broader policy discussion
to the extent that Josiah is a not a lawyer and b maybe said
something with respect to the murder. The fact that it was couched
right next to the conclusion of murder would make it seem perhaps
that he's implying that that bears on the murder analysis. to
the extent that he made that I think it's a forgivable error
and the statement is still relevant to other aspects of this
discussion including what people have pointed to namely the chilling
effect this might have on gun possession in this country and
>> I I think that that's going to be a hard argument for
Pisco to make cuz Conor's not going to feel like he like Connor
is never going to feel like leftists take that seriously. He's
going to feel like that's that's like when somebody gets mad
at you and they know you're Christian, they go, "Oh, that's not
very Christian of you, right? When they don't uphold any of those
values themselves, feels like they're just trying to use your
thing to cudle you with when they don't even believe it or understand
any of the the like um I don't know the
nuances of it. Come on." >> Because if you're saying that
the legality has and by the way, you're inviting a fight very
early on, but that's fine >> because I'm telling you the
intent behind my tweet. I'm telling you that I disagree with
Josiah. you want to bear down on it, which is fine when we have
a lot of other [__] to get into. That's fine. No,
we don't we don't need to. We can do it peacefully. We can do
it fiery, [laughter] but mostly peaceful conversation. Okay.
All right. So, the reason why I don't like the legality argument
and I think it's stupid as and it pissed me off and I understand
that you're saying that the underlying intention of Josiah's
tweet is different, which is fine and I understand it. I probably
wasn't even thinking about all the mega hypocritical see you
next Tuesdays who were like brain about the fact that this guy
had a pistol with two magazines. I probably wasn't even thinking
about that. I wasn't thinking about that. Okay. What I saw was
Josiah saying this guy had a legally permitted firearm. this
was murder. Okay? And so to me, the reason why that is dumb as
is because if let's let's just boil down the scenario. I'm an
illegal I'm a criminal or I don't have a concealed weapons permit.
Let's say I'm a sovereign citizen and I have a pistol in my backpack.
Okay? I don't have a concealed weapons permit and I'm in a state
that requires a concealed weapons permit. Identical scenario
by the state. The legality of the pistol has no bearing on me.
Okay. No. The second amendment doesn't bear on the deadly force
usage in the specific case. I'll grant you. what I think is relevant
from a second amendment perspective and what you have to contend
with is the implications of your determination in this case and
what it might have for gun rights down the line specifically
to it. Okay, if we adopt the Conor rule that this is objectively
reasonable, the reply from other people is, wow, this standard
is so low that you're going to chill exercise the second amendment
rights. And I think you have to contend with that and it's not
like I'm making this argument up. Everyone has been talking about
it. Everyone contend with this is going to chill Second Amendment
rights. Okay. If adopted, if your standard is adopted,
every concealed weapon carrier I know knows that they're doing
an inherently dangerous thing every time they place a firearm
on their body because they're reminded by liberals all the time.
The mere fact of owning a firearm like triples your chances of
that being successful. It like doubles or quintoubles your chance
of a family member dying to an accidental gun discharge. It um
you know, if you're actually in a use of force scenario, there's
so many different scenarios where people can mistake uses of
force. It's possible that you could kill someone on accident
or on purpose. >> How does Connor argue this right now
and not argue that Kyle Writtenhouse was morally incorrect for
what he did? I'm guessing Kyle Written House was morally correct
for what he did in Conor's eyes, right? But how do you argue
Kyle Written House is innocent and and totally morally correct
and then make this argument as well >> and be incorrect
in their intention and therefore go to jail for murder or manslaughter?
It's an inherently dangerous proposition to keep a firearm on
your person. And so as a result, that culture is already there.
And so to say, oh well, you know, if we state that bearing a
firearm and then trying to protest or interrupt a law enforcement
operation is um something that's going to chill Second Amendment,
the exercise of the Second Amendment, good. Okay. People should
know the risks inherent to carrying a pistol. People should know
the risks inherent to carrying a firearm. And if you can't do
so responsibly, then off. >> Yeah. But but that's that's
contingent on your false assumption that this person interfered
or otherwise was obstructing federal prerogatives, which he clearly
was not, >> which is why we need to back if it's the case.
If it's the case that there were good reason to believe. >> Sounds
like he's just saying Kyle Writtenhouse knew he was around and
might die. >> He were doing that. That's one thing. But
would you grant that? But but let's just take the other view.
If it were the case conditional, if someone thought as I do that
that was [__] stupid, that he wasn't being irresponsible
with his gun or irresponsibly interfering with our operations,
you would agree that the criticism would go through in that case
because then it's like, wait, wait, I'm putting myself at risk
even when I'm not being reckless. >> Okay. Would you would
you Okay. All right. So, what is the evidence that he that a
reasonable officer? And again, the officer who shot isn't the
officer who like pushes the woman. Just be clear about that.
Doesn'tffect my calculus. >> Oh, in what sense? Why would
it not?
Why would that affect my calculation
at the time of the question? I'm going to answer it. You ask
me question, I'm gonna answer it. The TOC is not reliant on the
individual officer being in a scrum with a bunch of other people.
He is backing up his other fellow officers, which is exactly
in his purview. I think we should take a chronologically. >> No,
no. I I understand that the TOC >> say that again in a
second. >> I understand that the TOC will, you know, you'll
be able to include the fact that it's in a scrum and things are
confusing. I'm not doubting that. But understand the rule you're
providing is an officer who arrives at a scrum who hasn't necessarily
seen this person interrupt a federal function or at least you
haven't established it. That the rule that you're proposing is
one that's independent of that. Do you understand that? at the
rule would not
>> TOC here meaning what just if anybody's I I went past
where they would have defined it probably I'm just curious if
anybody knows off the top of their head >> doesn't necessarily
include that situation because you don't have any good basis
to believe that a reasonable officer from his position would
have done the competitive acts that you're accusing them of doing
that they would have seen the hand touch the the belt even if
that were obstructive in that sense and because you don't have
otherwise we're in a loop [snorts] also hold on I need to tell
my chat something real quick okay this is a warning to everyone
in my chat okay like the stream share with your friends engage
test your members you got them if you're soy or if you're a rude
see you next Tuesday or a [__] I'm going to time
you out. The only the only thing is it's going to be 300 seconds.
So, it's not going to be a long time. But if you show up in your
I'm going to time you out. You show up in your So again, I'm
time out. Show up in your So again, I'm banning you. Okay. The
only people who have immunity are Oilers and Chippers. Okay.
But the people who pay my bills, if you're a regular and you're
going to see you next Tuesday, I'm going to kick you. You understand?
All right. Anyways, let's move chronologically. So, do do you
want to build up the video chronologically or do you want me
to narrativeize it and >> I mean is awesome. Yeah. Literally,
that's my philosophy. Okay. White names. White names barely even
human to tell >> Dispute the details as we narrativeize
>> Okay. So, tell me what wants to be, >> I would
like to. I think it will allow us to contend with details as
they >> One moment. >> Okay. So, for instance, you
say soy. What the does that mean? Disagree with your take. Correct.
You're in a timeout.
>> What the [__] Chipper. I'm guessing chipper
literally just means somebody who's bought a membership, right?
Membership. Chip. He's got a ship. He's got a chip. >> Uh,
okay. Let's get to this part and then I'll go over here.
Uh, I know that from from sports, you know, you call championships
chips. >> Okay. Um, >> chipping in. Could also be
that.
>> Um, roll it back to the beginning. >> Uh, okay.
Beginning past the comments over here, right? Um, I would like
it wherever the females are approaching the >> The females
are approaching the vehicle.
>> Correct. This one over here. >> You watch hockey?
Not as much recently. >> The key moment.
>> So, so far these are the females that approach the vehicle.
Um, give us your analysis. Do you know that this is the officer
who shot the one who they're talking to? Again, irrelevant to
my >> Okay, cool. Why is it relevant? Can you just explain
real quick? Why is it relevant whether or not this is the officer
if it's going to factor into your self-defense analysis? It needs
to be something that the officer would have known. Same thing
with the gun thing. You just made that point about the legally
operated gun, whether I get a permit. They need to be things
that the officer knows about. And so, why is it here? I can give
you a brief summary, but I would really appreciate it if we took
it chronologically because effectively what I'm trying to do
is I'm trying to put you in the eyes of the officers as the situation
unfolds to understand the continuum of force 100%. Why are you
saying you won't follow me down this road? >> I will, but
is there a reason you can't answer like the use of force is analyzed
from the perspective of the particular officer and what you would
have known about? Correct. >> Right. So if you if you want
the TOC if you want the totality of circumstances why wouldn't
you analyze the information as it becomes aware to the officers
involved in the incident >> the particular officer correct
>> sure and if you want to particularize it
I'm doing this I'm happy to do the announce you're talking about
but let's just be clear that >> I'm only on 1.5 his fast
>> dude Conor always does this >> sure will do it
>> that's what >> he looks like he's in crazy >> what
we have to do is analyze the information available to the one
or two officers actually shooting the guns. That's what the test
is. >> So, I've asked for this like 10 times. Can we do
it when we get there? >> Okay.
Happened. >> And and so for instance,
>> Sorry, I was muted. I was saying pause it right there.
>> Okay. Right here.
Now, I think that the initial officer has sand in his Okay, to
be clear, he he he has sand in his nethers, but we have two females
who are in the roadway who are 6 feet away, 5t away from
like I immediately, man, I I tend to like focus on stuff in debates
like this. Maybe there's a reason Pisco is not focusing on it.
Immediately I'm annoyed. Immediately Conor's focusing on somebody
who's not the guy who got shot that like I I'm like what is the
purpose? What are you doing here? You're just going to say this
officer having a bad day with somebody else affects another situation.
That can't be the >> ICE vehicle. If the ICE vehicle wanted
to back up, it would have to do so cognizant of where the females
are. The females have no lawful reason to be in the road. They're
not in a pedestrian crosswalk. They're in the cop's face. They're
yelling at them. They're pointing fingers and all that kind of
stuff. Do you think that a officer in good faith could view that
as a disruption of his law enforcement >> Depends what
you mean by disruption. That's what I answered like your question
about. So what do you mean by disruption? Do you mean >> Okay,
my answer is yes. >> Well, what do you mean by disruption?
>> I mean that if the let let's say that they're looking
for a suspect or something like that and the suspect is on the
other side of the street. If that officer wanted to run across
the street in order to engage in a law enforcement operation,
those women are in the way.
>> Anyway, sometimes it's like there is a level of being
close enough and irritating enough. It's like, okay, this does
rise to obstruction, but like reasonably if you're like 6 feet
away, like CO rules, you're like 6 feet away and you're just
yelling and you're recording or something. Okay, the cops don't
get to complain anymore. I know it's annoying, but Jesus, okay,
it's you got to you got to let them do their >> okay? Not
only that, if the vehicle needs to back up because they're at
like a 3/4 angle to the rear of the vehicle, and I'm not saying
the vehicle needs to back up, okay? It probably doesn't. Exactly.
Right. But at the same time, if it needed to back up, those women
are obstructing the vehicle.
If they needed to back up because of their presence there, they
would be in the way of the vehicle. I take obstruction to be
an intentional voluitional act with the per with a particular
purpose in mind. That's what I understand to be. and you use
the term and you use the term disruption. I'm just trying to
>> So the thing that saves this for both of them is just
say, "Okay, the second the cop wants to go to back up and he
says, "Hey, you're going to be in my way if I back up, but he
gets in his vehicle and he starts it and then they're still standing
there, then he could say, "You're now obstructing, right?" But
like the idea that you might be obstructing some hypothetical,
you're actually obstructing some hypothetical thing that officer
might do standing anywhere technically, right? like there is
some universe where this officer wants to walk directly through
where you are and you're you're hypothetically obstructing them
by standing anywhere near him,
right?
To follow your claim. If your claim is I can imagine scenarios
in which they would present a physical obstacle to what ISIS
is trying to do. I mean sure but that would also exist for everyone
on the [__] street. I can imagine scenarios where
they would present themselves. >> Are you allowed to be
in the street? Are you allowed to be in the street? And it's
considered if you're sometimes yes. Sometimes yes. Agreed. Sometimes
yes.
>> So hold on. Let's skip let's skip ahead a little bit
and I would appreciate it if you stopped being the defense attorney
and if we just started playing.
>> I think the answer here is well ICE officers can't actually
enforce the traffic laws
and
right they can't enforce those laws. They can't enforce like
jaywalking laws. So how are you how are you obstructing their
duties by
I don't see I don't see
Do you think that the Do you think that this officer could reasonably
So, for
>> if these ladies are on the side of the road and they're
blowing their whistles and saying ice, eat a you fat pigs, you
pieces of I hope you die, you're not gestapo, I hope you kill
yourself, I hope you suck your [__]
home, >> I don't think they can apply force to them or
detain them at all on those facts alone. Now, if they're 6 feet
away from the vehicle and they're doing the exact same thing,
do you think a reasonable officer could argue that this is this
is escalated to the point that they might be obstructing their
law enforcement duties? >> Not on that fact alone. No.
>> Okay. Not on that fact alone.
>> Don't they have to actively be obstructing something?
Is it Is it whether or not they're obstructing or whether or
not they have intent to obstruct?
Because those are two different things. Maybe they're thinking,
"Hey, I'm going to slow this guy down." and they're trying to
play the line, then I like I don't know, but you basically have
to go to do something. You get blocked. >> Can you foresee
a reasonable law enforcement officer believing that these two
women are obstructing their law enforcement duties or at least
having sufficient Hold on, let me phrase it because you're being
annoying as >> How? Wait, wait, how am I being annoying?
I'm telling you, you're being annoying because you're slowing
down the entire conversation and wrapping us around axle when
realistically you could just say yes or no. >> So yes or
no, let me >> Wait, what do you mean you could just say
yes or no? He says no. Like when when he says depends on the
context, that's no, but we could have more conversation and I
could get to yes. That's what that means. It means no. I don't
agree with you obviously.
But maybe depending on the context, I could in every situation.
Do I agree with this? No.
>> Let me use your favorite tactic. Let me let me use your
favorite tactic. Do you think this officer has detention authority
to uh detain or arrest these women right now based off of their
conduct? Yes or no?
>> Okay. I think you're wrong. >> Wait, what's the
crime against the >> But that's Connor's now slowing the
conversation down. That was obvious in everything Pisco said
up to this point. That was obviously true. What are we doing?
Why did you slow it down to say I need to yes or no you? The
answer was obviously no.
United States that they've committed >> the obstruction
of a lawful law enforcement operation which is something that
ICE and CBP can detain for. >> Wait a second. How have
they done obstruction in that case?
>> So if you look up the statute, I can pull it up. I have
incredibly vague.
It's incredibly vague. But they have no lawful purpose to be
in the roadway. They have no lawful purpose to be six feet away
from a vehicle. They're distracting law enforcement officers
by the mere fact that they're putting themselves in danger by
being in the roadway. And a law enforcement officer's job for
the crime >> is is to protect like life and liberty. So
yeah, they're already distracting from a law enforcement operation
by putting themselves in danger by standing in the middle of
a roadway. >> So So would yelling at them from the from
a safe place? >> No, it wouldn't. If they were on the sidewalk,
what's the imminent threat of injury or death? >> What?
No, I thought you said
Yeah, they're distracting from law enforcement officers conducting
their >> someone someone someone on the street six feet
away yelling at them. >> That's protected by the first
amendment.
>> That's protected by the first amendment. Getting in
the face of law enforcement officers screaming at them and obstructing
their path to conduct.
>> They're mixing these things together. Wait a wait a
second. So this is them. [clears throat] So describe to me what's
happening with this moment. See that? What is happening in this
situation?
>> They're obstructing. >> And by the way, I need
to add a caveat already because I'm giving you an incredible
amount of latitude. You're giving me zero, which is annoying
as >> What latitude am I not giving you?
>> What's that? >> What latitude? >> Because
you could because you could just say what would be argued in
court versus what you specifically believe and we could move.
>> I don't think that this is a crime. What I'm looking
at right there, is that a
>> I think I think I'm laying out what Pisco means. So,
I don't know. I it would be interesting if I could ask Connor
because I think I'm laying out precisely what Pisco means. It's
implied in the things he says. Like he'd have to say more words
than he is saying now to say what I'm saying, which is what I'm
inferring from what he said. It's like, but it's the natural
inference you would make based on the things he said. Why don't
you just say yes or no if you think this is a problem? If you
think this is like obstruction. Well, he's he's obviously he
obviously doesn't think it's obstruction. Obviously, >> it
could it 100% could be argued to be obstructing a a lawful law
enforcement operation which gives the officer detention authority?
>> I I don't based on what crime they're talking to an
officer in a car. >> You think they're just talking to
the officer in the car? >> That's what we're seeing right
now. Maybe there's other footage that shows them doing other
stuff.
>> Okay. I I think
you're wrapping around an axle and I don't care. Can we put a
pin? Like, we can put a pin in this. >> Then why the did
you even walk down this direction? If you don't care, Carter,
you're the person who brought it down. Like, you're trying to
argue that this could be obstruction. This is obstruction in
your mind. And then you make that argument. You're like, Pisco,
you're like disagreeing with me. That means you're getting wrapped
around an axle and I don't care about this. Then what the [__]
did you bring this up for?
Is this just every time I get to watch Pisco talk now it's just
people gaslighting him because he's being precise? That's like
that's like the Pisco show now. You just get to watch people
come on and totally gaslight this guy because he's trying to
be precise and figure out what people think.
And he's been told he's an So he's trying to remain nice while
he does it, while it happens to him. He's trying to remain kind
and not call these people freaks, right?
And it's it's just a little frustrating to watch sometimes >> and
say you don't think this is sufficient for detention or ordering
these women to disperse. I disagree with you. I I wholeheartedly
disagree with you. You want me to pull up the federal
>> I'll just pull up the federal statute. Give me this.
I already mentioned in my >> I already mentioned in my
chat that this is something that if there was a
>> meaning
of the of the rules or laws then um All right. Hold on.
All right.
Start listening to what I'm saying or I'm going to ban you. You
understand? >> Hang on. I'm just fix my my my real quick.
One second. I'm just fixing my
>> But not saying talking. Okay. >> I wasn't trying
to interrupt you. I think there might have been just a quick
>> No, it's fine. Uh, if a criminal flees from officers
into a public crowd, Connor would want the whole crowd arrested
for obstruction.
no. Well,
yeah, maybe. Like, basically, you need the intent element is
what the DK guys say. The the donation, you need the intent element.
>> I'm I'm giving people times out. And if once again,
if you tell me to chill the [__] out, you're getting
banned. Okay. I I timed you out, Josh,
>> because I don't know if you're being or not. But Josh,
next time you come back and you say, "Connor, you need to chill."
You're getting banned.
Just a heads up. All right. >> What's the statute? >> Let's
pull this up.
>> So, let me mute so I'm not echoing, but yeah, I'm going
to pull up a statute. We're going to make sure that we have the
same statute. We're going to read it together. Okay.
>> This is more Yeah, based on what we're arguing here,
this is a little rough, man. This is more where I'm at. Sorry,
where I'm at on my read. >> Oh, Josh just came in my chat.
>> Muted himself again. freedom. Come on. Come on.
>> Find my Okay. I'm not finding my
>> Um, is it possible that you could just tell me the statute
real quick? >> Um, so there's one I think that's like
18. Let me just make sure. 181. Um,
and
here I'll show it to my audience, but that's citation you can
show to yours. Just let you know it's 1811. That's the one that
they said in a recent um opinion that was analyzing some of the
[__] [snorts] >> Like somebody's saying he
seems like he's mad right now. I was saying that he did just
get banned on Twitter and he did build up that account. He uses
Twitter a lot. He built up that account over like years and years.
Has like thousands of followers on it. All of his mutuals. I
could see why that would like actually pick you off like why
he might be cranky. I must have been like two, three, four days
ago. >> That's the one. >> How did he get banned?
I have no idea. He doesn't seem like somebody who calls for violence.
>> They decided in a recent um opinion that was analyzing
some of the [__]
>> I'm just going to show it to my audience and we'll go
back to you. >> I think it's the second time he's been
mad, though. >> interestingly enough. >> And so it
um said in section 1114 of this title um and then
also forcibly assaults or intimidates any person who formerly
serves as a person whatever designated there. And so this statute
which they cited requires
>> Okay. [snorts] Well, hold on. Number one, we should
probably read that again. But 18 [clears throat] US code.
>> Oh, is that
how would you forcibly intimidate somebody? Would forcibly not
apply to assault or intimidate?
Can you forcibly intimidate somebody or would it just be intim
it's any person?
>> Code 1502 resistance to an extradition agent. Do we
think that ICE is an extradition agent?
>> Why not? >> Because they don't do extradition.
I don't have a reason to believe that. Maybe there's case.
Uh yeah, let me Google that definition and then I want to hear
your thing again. So let me let me uh just Google who is considered
an extradition agent in the United States and then let me hear
your statute again. Okay. >> Well, it feels like forcibly
assaults or intimidates. Like forcibly must only apply to assaults.
And Pisco is saying there's an or there
like I'm guessing forcibly assaults.
I'm guessing forcibly doesn't actually like apply to each of
these necessarily
uh I don't even know what the difference between forcibly assaulting
and intimidating would be.
Yeah, it just it doesn't make sense to me why you even included.
>> Uh what I'm saying is that that statute most often applies
to US marshals. So I won't use my statute. Let's use your your
statute. >> So read me your statute again. >> In
general, uh we don't have to do sub two because it's sub one
um that's identified here. And I assume for p for purposes that
um this would include yeah I'm going to assume that this includes
any employer officer of the United States. So an ICE agent is
an employer officer of the United States. I'll grant that whoever
forcibly assaulted impedes intimidated or interferes with any
person designated as we just looked while engaged in or account.
>> No because clauses are going to matter >> So you're
saying forcibly applies to all of them. So 18 USC 111. >> But
is it that is 100% not the way I'm going to be reading that.
Well, I'm
>> So, I I don't like the grammar here in terms of it.
Listen, I if I had to, you know, bet money on it, Pisco would
be the person I trust who went to law school who knows how to
interpret these these statutes, right? And if he says that's
the way it works, I would take his word for it until I heard,
you know, from an equally from an equal opposing authority basically
that authority that was the other way. But to me, it doesn't
opposes comma impedes, intimidates, or interferes with any person
designated. You're you're applying forcibly
>> What's forcible resistance? What's forcible opposition?
What's forcibly impeding? What's forcible intimidation? >> Wait,
hold on. Force forcible does make sense on all the rest of those
and interferes. Which is why I was like, oh, the first one it
might make sense. To me, intimidates is the only one that doesn't
make sense because intimidates would be a subsection of any of
these other ones in my opinion. And so it would be >> forcable
intimidation doesn't apply to all seven of the words immediately
afterwards. Forcible applies to assault. >> Yeah. Yeah.
So, I'm just interpreting it the way that
>> forcibly resists makes sense. Forcibly opposes makes
sense. Forcibly impedes makes sense or forcibly interferes. It
actually applies to all of those make sense. And he's like, what
does it mean with each of these? It's like, no, that makes total
sense. >> District Court uh filing had it in federal court,
but I'll I'll find that decision. Just give me one second to
do that. Okay. Uh yep. Minnesota federal courts. Uh this court
this would be assault. This would be like assault already. Kimoto
marks. Okay. And to
people are saying, "Is yelling too loud equals impeding?" No,
I think it would be forcable. What I would say is that the officer,
rightly or wrongly, regardless of whether or not it gets thrown
out of court, he's going to say that I am incapable of backing
up my vehicle in a way that it might be necessary. I am incapable
of pursuing on foot the like somebody that I need.
So, that's going to break down to were you actually impeded or
were you were you perceiving the possibility that you could be
impeded?
Right? Cuz that's what Conor Connor is playing like a shifty
game here where he keeps talking about possibly this could happen.
Possibly that could happen. It's like okay but were you impeded?
Did you say hey get out of my way? I'm trying to get out of here.
You're blocking me. Did you do something like that? Or were you
just like hypothetically if I try to get in my vehicle immediately
to chase somebody? They'd be impeding me cuz I'm pretty sure
that doesn't count. And that's where forcibly would actually
come in here because it would require like actual the actual
thing happening, right? That it can't be the intent to. And it
says right here, it's not the intent to. You need to do the thing.
You need to forcibly block. You can't. Yeah, you can't theoretically
or have intent to and be arrested for it. Need to apprehend because
of the proximity of these people. So, if these people were on
the sidewalk blasting their whistles, nobody would give a The
reason why they're going to argue that it's an impeding is because
they're going to say that these people are all up in our you
know what I'm saying? It's not that hard to track.
>> Where is this opinion? Um, and guys, it was recently
>> totally mid belch from Pisco. Not cool.
>> Where is this? >> Oh, wait. Sorry. That was from
Connor. That was clearly from Connor.
>> Guys, it was recently it was recently stayed on other
grounds. It was stayed on on the the scope of it. It was applying.
It was basically on the nature of the GRO, not on the um >> not
on the uh finding of the statuto [snorts] holding here that there
was no
>> uh suspicion for the Fourth Amendment
>> Incorrect. Die. Die. Doobie. When you're saying that
this cop had sand in his >> I agree with you. Uh,
oh, here we go. I found the
I found the case number. Okay, one sec. I'm I'm about to get
it. So, this is
Turvy Gnome. Tinurvy Gnome
Gnome. Um, case listener. Okay, we'll go to the opinion
turvy gnome. Sorry guys, just give us a second.
um can you entertain them while I find
>> Absolutely. I'll just give them my
>> So if if somebody goes, "Oh, so so soy. Um you know,
they weren't using this statute in good faith." That actually
doesn't change my argument at all. So the the my argument with
Pisco right now that we're trying to nail down is that 18 US
code 111 assaulting resisting or impeding certain officers employees.
says forcible assault. Forcibly, excuse me, forcibly assaults,
resists, oh, excuse me, let me read the entire thing. Whoever,
so anybody, right, forcibly assaults, I'm saying that's one clause.
>> Resists, opposes, impedes or intimidates or interferes
with any person designated in section 1114 of this title while
engaged in or on account of the performance of official duties
or blank blank blank. Oh, >> what is going on with Pisco's
tech? Can somebody get this guy a computer? What is happening?
His stream is like consistently falling apart. And I say that
as somebody who has been the guy whose stream is consistently
falling apart. Okay, I feel like I can safely call this out.
What the is happening? >> Shall where the act violation
of the section cost one simple assault be fined under the title
or imprisoned not more than one year. So what I'm saying is if
this is a statute that we're we're going under the reason why
I was told uh while going through training for uh how to read
a statute because cops are very good at reading statutes, right?
But at the same time, reading a statute is important because
there's case law where you could argue forcible. And so as a
result, if you say forcibly resists, forcibly opposes, forcibly.
>> Oh, it literally has been decided in this specific case,
then that's going to change the dynamic because Pisco is going to
say, well, even if you're arguing that they're impeding them,
they didn't use force to do so. >> Okay, Pisco, it's actually
up that you're going to let him keep ranting on this. Okay, don't
let him keep ranting on this while you have the answer that proves
he's a right here. Okay, that's >> therefore the statute
doesn't apply. Whereas if I was in a court case, I would say
no, forcible only applies to assault. It doesn't apply to impede.
Therefore, at this point, this officer because these women are
engaged in other crimes to I know they're lowle crimes, but they're
engaged in other crimes to impede a law enforcement operation.
This applies and therefore they're subject to detention and arrest
and therefore the subsequent shove and pepper spray is therefore
justified. So like not the shove, the shove is kind of hardcore,
right? But but like the the question that Pisco and I are kind
of twisting him about on is does this officer even if he has
sand in his excuse me does he have detention authority and that's
what we're arguing right now I found it just a heads up. So this
is from uh the recent opinion from tinure but it's citing binding
eth circuit president um from 2024 so it's not like it's old
president. This is from the eth circuit court of appeals which
again is binding in the eighth circuit both on the court but
also on the people who are you know following the law in the
circuit.
Uh, defendants argue that Miss Tiner cannot show retalatory animist
because the ICE officers who arrested her had at least a reasonable,
if mistaken, belief, that there was probable cause, to arrest
her for a violation of 18 USC section 111. The court disagrees,
section 111 makes it a crime to quote forcibly assault, resist,
impede, intimidate, or interfere with the federal officer engage
in the performance of their official duties. 18 USC uh section
111 A sub1, which we're looking at, quote, because forcibly,
as used in that statute, necessarily modifies each of the listed
verbs that follows it, citing United States v. Davidson 108 uh
F4706 at 712 from the 8th Circuit 2024. A violation of 111 would
require some aspect or threat of force. Hold on. Read that last
half sentence. >> Because forcibly as used in the statute
necessarily modifies each of the listed verbs that follows it,
said United States v. Davidson. A violation of 111 would require
some aspect or threat of
>> Um isn't standing like 6 feet away. Is that like technically
threatening force? Don't do it, Connor. Don't do it, Connor.
Don't do it, Connor. Okay. So, even if we find it unreasonable
because I'm not scared of two women yelling at me and blowing
whistles or whatever, do you think that an officer would be able
to write A REPORT SUCH THAT [screaming] THEY would be able to
state, oh, well, everybody else was on
why why would you take this route? Why? I just like, oh,
you already found that this your opinion going into this, just
remember, was that that was freedom of speech, Connor.
remember that you just you gave the opinion that that was freedom
of speech. You can't go back on that now. Well, actually technically
they might have felt really threatened by >> on the sidewalk
and these two women walked up to the car. >> Wait, and
therefore I was in fear. >> And then he's going to go,
yeah, but you could be threatened by somebody's like protected
speech. It's like, yeah, but then would a reasonable person agree
that you could like do some action, arrest them, let's say, because
you were scared that them exercising their voice with no threat
with no threat of violence, no implied threat or
it's it's all going to loop back >> that they were, you
know, going to forcibly impede our lawful duties. >> Can
we I think they could go 100 like it could get thrown out, but
I 100% >> sounds like what you were just arguing. I provided
the stat. >> Oh, it is it is the thing. Okay. Hey, standing
anywhere feasibly you could you could feasibly impede me by standing
anywhere. So now now I can arrest you. I could arrest anybody
who's mad at me in this area because possibly they could impede
me. Are they impeding me now? No. But they could. In fact, I
infer that they would. So now they're on you said you had a bookmark.
I provided the statue based on memory cuz I read this. I read
it correct. >> Obviously not the way anything. You said
that the reason that your opinion still held was because forcibly
only applied to assault. I read you the binding eth circuit president
or at least the disagreed with it. Okay. Okay. And so now your
point is well so are you granting that it would be illegal to
uh or there would be no reasonable suspicion to stop these women
because they haven't done anything that would put them under
the ambit of um section >> Uh no and I would cite the last
half sentence which is what? Read it. A violation of section
111 would require some aspect or threat of force. What's the
aspect or threat of force? Threat of force. Yeah. >> Right.
So the threat of force and by the way I don't have sane in my
So once again I would not be arresting these women nor would
I be trying to stick stick them with it. Okay. But I think you
and I both know that what people get stuck with and what people
try to phrase in order to justify an arrest is different than
what's actually people are going to be held accountable for.
>> So what I'm saying is that they didn't have legal authority
at least from all if this is all we have I'm not saying it's
not another video but if this is all we have I don't think there's
any legal authority to detain them. You seem to be saying that
there might be
>> uh correct. Yeah. And not just I don't find it reasonable
reasonable but I think you could articulate it within a police
report. >> you can articulate anything in a police report.
I can articulate like that stole my mom and but that's like the
problem at all. >> Hold on. Do you think do you think that
when this officer ordered these women out of the roadway, he
had the lawful lawful ability to do so? >> Um, I'm not
sure. Order by by threat of um >> see this is this is what
I don't like. >> You're saying I don't know. Do you think
the officer believed he had set >> Um I assume that they
all think that they have the authority whatever they want. So
yes,
>> come on, man. >> You asked me a question about
their subjective belief. They subjectively believe they have
the authority to push anyone they want to push. And in this case,
yeah, they thought they had the authority to to make orders and
make that doesn't mean that they're right about it. that we were
examining whether or not they were authorized, not whether or
not they thought they were. >> You think that my position
is they didn't think they were authorized? You think I'm telling
you, oh, I think they knew what they were doing was illegal.
>> These guys, these guys, uh, they're actually aware that
they're breaking the law. They're actually aware that they could
be held responsible for all of their actions. They're actually
aware of this. No, if they were aware of it, they probably wouldn't
be doing it to be honest with you. If they didn't think they
had like supreme authority right now, they probably, a lot of
them would not be there. A lot of them would be like, "Oh, this
is I'm getting into something I can't really defend. I'm going
to I'm going to be in a lot of trouble going forward.
Okay.
So, >> are you mad at me for some reason? My contention
would be I'll forward an argument and then hopefully we can move
>> Oh, no.
>> well, fine.
>> Is Connor actually just saying it's possible for the
cop to lie about this in his report, so it's potentially reasonable
or justified?
>> My contention would be I'll forward an argument and
then hopefully we can move
My contention would be rightly or wrongly they believe that 18
USC 1111
wrongly. Right. Wrongly.
Where's the where's the eighth circuit at? Where where's the
eth circuit in the country? >> The eth circuit um oversees
this um oversees the discrim. I believe. Oh my god. If I if this
is wrong. Yeah, it does. Oh my god, you scared me. Eth circuit
is >> I mean that's not necessarily my point. I I was trying
to see if they had a reputation for being aggressive. That's
>> what the Wait, so but that doesn't matter because that's
the law. That's binding president. >> Yeah, it is binding
president. But at the same time, you would presume that the officers
if they were uh they would be briefed on what is forcible on
whether it's liberal. What are you scratching that stuff? Like
what the >> No, no, no, no, no. This is Dude, you're you're
acting like this is crazy. But Hawaii and California have consistently
found like things that are binding precedent that I find to be
wholly unconstitutional in reference to firearms. So, as a result,
like, yeah, depending on the court, they're either going to have
a progressive or conservative lens in the reference to the way
that they argue statutes. Like, are you
>> Yeah, but hold on. The the thing is is if you're in
Hawaii or California, you should you should follow the law, right?
I I don't know what he's trying to say. Pisco is just talking
about what the law >> In good faith argue with me right
now that the Supreme Court of the United >> By the way,
I just
I can't believe personally that the Supreme Court would disagree
on that. That feels like it's got to be in a dictionary. That's
got to be in something. No, like like the idea that you have
some preceding adjective and it applies to all of the things,
all of the verbs in a sentence or something, right? Forcibly
assault. That's got to be something in law that is just decided
that like if I write it this way, if I do the grammar this way,
it does apply to all of the things. That's got to be the case,
right? There can't be laws that are written ambiguously where
half of them are interpreted one way and half of them are interpreted
the other way. That can't be, in my opinion, that would be totally
insane. That's got to be just within the like the meta of legal
analysis or or law writing like legal writing that's got to be
just decided. That's how big the ground >> states isn't
arguing in a biased manner based off their political perspective.
And by the way, it's not reliant on this at all. >> It's
not relying on what the law is, whether or not this was they
have legal authority to stop them. >> Okay. You're being
okay. Am I being unfair right now? Am I being
explain? Yes. I'm
>> Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude. Why wouldn't
you just make that a rule? Can Can we get somebody to Yeah. Can
we get somebody to write like a computer language for the law
or something where where like you decide something like that
you just make it a rule and you rewrite all of the laws where
that happens where it doesn't work that way
like just re rewrite all of them on the books so that you could
it feels like you should just do that. No,
if there are cases where it does seem to change the meaning of
the law then have the discussion but Jesus >> dude unfair.
>> I think my yes or no questions are going to answer this
uh pretty definitively. Okay. Do you think that ICE is going
to use 18 USC11 in order to argue that these women were subject
to detention or lawful orders to disperse? >> Yes, because
they've tried it before in
>> Okay. Do you think that they could slant a police report
in order to justify these people's detention and or arrest and
they could even put it up before a judge who will then determine
whether or not this was sufficient to meet the the guidance the
>> Pisco?
Do you think ICE would lie? Do you think ICE would just Do you
think members of the Trump administration would just go to a
US court and tell lies? Pisco, could you are you saying that
that that might not happen? No. Obviously, obviously, Connor,
that is going to happen. That can't possibly have a bearing on
the conversation. What What is your purpose of just saying,
>> threshold of threat of violence, whatever your direct
quote is." Um, the answer to that question, the answer to that
question is either yes or I'm not
>> Like I'm just trying to think of the most absurd lies
the Trump administration have told in court. It's got to be something
around the uh the insurrection. Not the insurrection, but the
the stolen election, right? Like they just they just straight
up lie about everything all the time.
Yeah, of course they'll lie about this. They said Renee Good
was a terrorist. They said this guy was a terrorist. what you
mean by could um and also depending on the factual and also depending
on the factual um if there's other evidence of them doing stuff
that would constitute that. I'm just going off of this. So, I'm
just there could be other stuff that would put them under that.
I'm just going off of this. This isn't showing that and I would
be shocked. >> Yeah, I know. I know how to I know how to
cut through the bull if those ladies walked up to the vehicle
and they were standing in front of the vehicle and they they
>> were they were screaming and yelling and pooping their
pants and all that kind of stuff. They're in the front of the
>> Yeah. probably
do do you think the Do you think >> um Miskf has all the
documents censored? Missy Elliot, that's the difference. So,
I don't mind covering Misk stuff. He's He censored all the documents
and he's reading them himself, so he's not going to read the
names out, right? He's just reading censored documents on stream.
That's like a big difference. >> Law enforcement officers
have to like sit there and wait because it's not a forcable impeding.
>> No, I think that that No, I think that would be a forcable
intimidation probably. Yeah. >> Okay. Then then that that
is sufficient for me to say that this officer is stretching because
he could get into his vehicle. off, right?
>> Okay. So, he's not going to because he's going to argue
18 US code 1011 the same argumentation he would if those women
were standing in front of the vehicle and he's going to put that
in front of >> that detention. But would you think he was
wrong regardless of if they will do that? Would you agree with
them? >> Okay. Mean yeah I think he's going to
>> that's so you don't think they have reasonable suspicion
to detain these
>> No, I do stretch stretching the law stretching the law
and pushing as far as you can is not itself prohibited. But you
would say it's stretching the law. As in not in compliance with
it. >> Yeah. As in like I think that >> speaking
of more Pegasus,
I noticed that there was a documentary
discussing the problem. Okay. >> This is Bmpton on I forgot
this got released until somebody mentioned more Pegasus. So I'm
the racist here. Really? And I will want to watch this at some
point. Okay. We will be watching this at some point. >> The
court is overly narrow and applying forcible to all.
>> Okay. That's just saying you just agree with that in
front of a judge. >> I know. You're just saying you disagree
with the eth circuit, but they're bound as they're standing there,
they're bound by the eighth circuit. >> Okay. Do you think
that do you think that right now there's probably like a dozen
cases? I'm actually getting pissed >> Why are you What
did I do wrong? >> Because we have so we have so much more
ground to >> This is your point, right? >> This is
not This is not critical to the overall event. >> So Connor,
it's your point. You were asking me whether I agree there's legal
authority to detain. I'm not granting that based on this. That's
why you're not you're not their lawyer. You're not >> I'm
not acting as their lawyer. [clears throat] I'm acting as you
and I having a conversation. When I when I ask you specifically
whether or not an officer could detain these people based off
of the circumstances you're saying,
>> okay, why do you have to ask that, dude? What? Here's
Conor's cheat code. Uh, let's just say, you know, for the sake
of argument, ICE is like totally crazy. These people are like,
you know, barely trained. They're getting paid a bunch of money
to be here. They're mostly power hungry. They could easily do
whatever they want to these people. Like, like we wouldn't say
it's morally good, but like we do agree they could do crazy [__]
right? They could shoot people. could arrest people. They're
not going to follow the law. If you just said it like that, then
of course Pisc would say yeah, I'm sure they would. I'm sure
they would try. >> Maybe. And I can't work with that answer.
You either got to say yes or no. If you say no, then I disagree
with you. If you say yes, then we move on. >> Well, I think
based on what I've seen the answer is no. I don't think they
have legal authority to arrest them or detain them. >> Okay,
we disagree. Let's move to the next point. >> Okay, reveal.
>> I I think at this point, Hold on, pause. I think at
this point they either do have the lawful authority to tell these
women to disperse or they're subject to arrest and or they can
operate under that presumption and put it in front of a judge
for judgment and therefore they do have detention authority.
>> That's that's the premise under which I'm operating.
>> And in your view, what would what was what is their
comment so far that rises in your mind? Not what they could argue,
not what a judge would find, but in your mind would constitute
forcible assault
>> Hold on. Um, Cam, just so you know, [clears throat]
just so you know,
we don't laugh at Tetone for having schizophrenia, unless it's
basically saying we don't believe him, right? We don't laugh
at him like crying and sobbing about his schizophrenia and how
it's made his life really hard. We factor it in in the analysis,
okay? Like, we mostly just cover the things Tech says and we
laugh at him. when when Andrew is like breaking down because
of his depression, because of his, you know, his bipolar disorder.
I'm not gonna That's the thing where I'm like, okay, I'm gonna
It was a happy cry, but it's still the same thing. It's a happy
cry
that is coming on the back of him feeling like relief that he
is no longer
I I personally am not going to make fun of that. >> Impedment,
intimidation, or interference um as construed by the Exirca.
>> I think impeding and uh intimidation is if I was writing
the report, I read it. No, no, no. But do do you think that you
think that that's what these people are doing right now? Forcibly
intimidated or
>> Uh, no. But I'm I'm also not a huge.
>> It feels like you're picking at me for asking that.
>> No. Well, because because what's going to happen is
your audience is going to soy out and they're going to view this
as because Connor thinks he's not a even though he really is.
And he wouldn't use force in order to get these women to disperse.
Connor is incorrect and that these officers have detention authority.
Therefore, everything that follows is like fruit of the rotten
tree. And I don't think that argument is making that
audience. First of all, don't listen, the audience is what the
audience is, but the Supreme Court has held and I'll grant you
this. Just because there's an unlawful detention that precipitates
a use of deadly force doesn't mean that the use of force is per
unreasonable. I'm the first to grant that that I don't even think
this is that relevant to the analysis to be honest with you.
It's a side point that people have pointed out like what business
is this have even like stopping this woman. But I don't think
it
>> I think I think it has some effect if there's like a
coin flip situation later, but you probably have to analyze the
situation, right? That's the whole point of saying well no it
doesn't it you know it doesn't make it not deadly or not appropriate
deadly force later automatically you'd have to analyze it right
we could all come up with some hypothetical where deadly force
later on would make sense >> terms the actual it's not
like the most important point to the use of force analysis and
I'm the first to grant it I'm just trying to you want to appreciate
you granting that but when you start fighting me on these details
it starts to feel like you're pushing in that direction
>> it doesn't matter man you said you said what you needed
to say in order to you did your BDSM afterare okay you slapped
me in the face a little bit you know you spit spit in my face
a little bit go this is a little intense can you relax a
[__] you. [__] are you talking about?
What the [__] are you talking about?
Oh, wait. Hold on. [laughter] Did somebody else Wait, did somebody
else do this exact bit?
Did somebody else do this exact bit with regards to Pisco that
we could think of? Did I Did I remember this? Am I remembering
this clip correctly?
Didn't
I feel like somebody else did this exact bit where Pisco was
having to do afterare with people and >> a little bit and
then you relaxed a little So, I appreciate your BDSM after. >> So,
so relaxing was me like throwing you a bone. That was relaxing.
>> Yeah. Relatively speaking, because basically if some
of your uh rsert audience goes, "Oh, well, you conceded that
the eighth circuit forcible doesn't apply to all of these things.
You also conceded that you wouldn't perceive this as a forcable
threat or impeding. Therefore, all of your subsequent argumentation
is flawed. What you've done by stating out, >> uh, it's
funny because I don't think this person is necessarily Mexican,
but hold on. Uh, guys, I've changed my mind. The USA should allow
all attractive female Mexican illegal immigrants and ban all
men white women will form SS brigades overnight.
Uh Trump should hire me for commissioner of US customs and border
protection. I will solve the immigration crisis crisis immediate
or instantly. As future secretary of state, I would approve the
attractive female visa. We call it the DD visa. Of course, I
will need to do regular in-depth reviews of the applicants to
ensure the administration is properly doing its job. May need
a PP, a long PP for this one. Okay. And it's a picture of Who
is that? Wait, who is that? That's Oh, that's Pinky Chu, right?
That's Pinky Chu. Uh, I don't know that, Quan, because he's not
mentioning it directly. He was mentioning it directly today.
You think I'm going to get let people just like abuse that all
the time? I don't think it was abuse abusing it at all. I think
that guy is legitimately having major issues that like literally
as soon as as soon as he told me what was going on, as soon as
he said what was going on, I'm like, "Oh, literally everything
about this guy makes sense."
And I'm not I'm not even getting mad at you. I said if you guys
want to go start that guy, that's on you, man. You'd go do that.
That's fine. I'm not going to tell you you're wrong. I literally
said I have a personal thing here. I'm not going to do it.
Who's Pinky Chu? I mean, it feels inappropriate to go from a
picture that is already lewd of Pinky Chu to do the who's Pinky
Chu bit. Okay. Feels just a little You're doubling. You're doubling
up. Okay. Don't deport big Don't deport big booty Latinos. Alex
Stein9,
dude. Okay. Wow. Wow. If only somebody had told Legal Bindset
who's uh who the defender. Yeah. The defend the applicant in
this case was you might have flipped sides entirely. >> Wow.
Even if your audience isn't listening to it because let's face
it, 70% of Twitch and YouTube politics are based off of emotion,
not off of the
>> Tom Foolery won. Frankly,
yeah, maybe. Maybe. what you said is sufficient for me to move
forward which is effectively that the courts find that even if
the initial
>> I think I think these memes are funny
>> ever is not fully justified there's still things that
can be brought out >> subsequently
let me so your audience if they saw out I can tell them to go
[__] >> okay perfect and let me just make that
point and emphasize it further now there could be some facts
um and the court might determine officer hazard like later on
or whatever but you can't just conclude because there's initial
violation of fourth amendment or some kind of unlawful seizure
that therefore they use a force afterwards is per se unjustified.
You actually need to run the analysis and these circumstances
might be relevant for their factual um relevance as opposed to
the legal aspect that um that I think is less strong. Um but
again that you have to run the analysis on the use of force without
just like trying to do a shortcut around it by pointing to this.
Um so that's yeah Connor's right about that. I just don't think
that there's a basis and there could be also to leave it all
out there. There could be other video that shows them doing that
would constitute
>> this is uh charging Jim and blank this conversation
you're having. This is kind of why I just don't I personally
he called it a time time was what he called it. Eth Oh, he also
called it ethical objectification or something like that. Yes.
Um but blank and charging Jim you guys talked about techone.
I do think the idea that he's like unmedicated schizophrenic
kept to his stream schedule where he streamed like 5 hours a
day, seven days a week for years.
I just think that's impossible. I don't think that's a thing
that could ever happen. I think he might have it. Maybe he's
got some sort of like uh like schizipple thing going on. I I
don't know, but it's not it's not diagnosed
schizophrenia or I do believe he would have a very hard time
functioning at the level he functioned for a very long period
of time.
Um yeah, it just seems unlikely given especially with the you
know the testimony that Msk provided where he says he doesn't
let take his medication because he doesn't like how it makes
him >> you know a forceable resistance or whatever. And
I haven't seen it yet. just going off of like the second and
a half that we have here. So, those are all caveats. I'm happy
to grant that I'm being chill. I just don't think you should
be like pissing me for asking these questions and like rounding
it out. I'm trying to help you. >> Uh, yeah, it's not you.
>> Okay. All right. Well, you want to
>> Reveal what happened. We see Freddy walking about filming
a group of protesters who are speaking with a federal agent.
>> He's And again, I agree. I think that they're speaking
to them and I don't think so far that we've seen any basis of
this is just my opinion. You can disagree, of um, you know, rational
basis for detention. Now, this person is almost certainly violating
the statute of the state of Minnesota, but the authority for
the ICE officers relates to uh crimes against United States.
I'm not aware of any general authority they have to to detain
for crimes against states. But instead, >> what I saw is
that they can uh detain for local crimes or whatever, but then
they have to coordinate with local law enforcement to enforce
said crimes. >> Oh, maybe they can. I'm just not aware
of that. If that authority exists, I'm not aware of it, but perhaps
it does. Holding a cell phone in one hand, the other hand is
empty.
It's just over 30 seconds before the shooting when a protester
is pushed to the ground. >> Here, pause. Yeah. thought
on that? >> Okay, rewind
3 seconds. >> Okay. And let's watch let's watch the shove
together >> before the shooting when a protester is pushed
to the ground.
>> Okay. Do law enforcement officers have like So, for
instance, the the same way that state attorneys have uh discretion,
>> do law enforcement officers have the authority to go
shove this old lady over? Is that is that something that they
are vested with the power to do, Pisco? Yes or no? >> Law
enforcement officers have discretion as well, right? Yes. Where
they can choose to arrest or they can choose to disperse depending
on the level of the crime? Yes. >> Okay. So, if we have
detention authority, but you can pepper spray somebody and or
actually, you know what? That was a good idea. I'm going to hold
on a second. That's a good idea. Let's do that. Okay. So, if
you're in reference to the continuum of force, okay, uh you can
pepper spray somebody, you can go hands-on at the lowest level
of force, which is passive resistance. Okay. So if this person
believed that they could detain this person under 18 USC 1111
and they were making a choice between what they could do, they
could either pepper spray them or push them out of the roadway
and then dip out because a threat has passed or they can detain
them. >> When you say do you mean legally they're allowed
to? >> I I think so long as it's reasonable use of force.
So I wouldn't grant that. >> I don't I think that shove
was a little brutal, but I still think it would be contextualized
as going hands on quote unquote which would still get the passive
resistance level. >> Well, I'm just wondering what is the
uh what would make this reasonable like in virtue of what is
this reasonable? What is the goal that he's accomplishing by
pushing her this way? >> Okay, let me give you the police
report then. I was asking you question. >> Yeah. While
conducting a lawful operation at the blocks of XYZ ABC, uh I
>> he Connor apparently says we don't have to why even
have debates on this if this is going to be your point? Why would
you have any debates on this at all on the legality at least?
Right. He's basically arguing, well, you know, they're going
to write a police report that says they they pushed them because
of this. It's like, yeah, we've watched them lie. We watched
them say that this guy was like hospitalized with internal bleeding.
the guy who shot Renee Good, right? We've we've just watched
them lie. It's like the whole point is watching and seeing like
is it reasonable? Not wondering what they're going to what lie
they're going to make up. Oh, could they make up a lie? Yeah,
they're going to make up a lie. Obviously, >> is your stream
okay? Is your stream >> Someone accident
it fully. Give me a second. >> Don't worry about it. I
just want to make sure that you're >> No, no, it's important.
I was uh I was timing people out and banning people because they
were being
um but you know what I'm going to do? I'm just gonna put my chat
away totally. Okay. >> I'm gonna let
>> And then I'll let them be later or Well, hold on. Let
me
Give me a second.
Dead air, but I don't care.
All right, let's do this.
It's like me last night playing Overwatch.
Had like some bad game or no, sorry, Marvel Rivals had some bad
game and people were like could play. I'm like, "Yeah, you know
what? Actually, I'm just I'm just going to Twitch. [__]
you guys." Hey, shut the kickstream off, you [__]
loser.
Give me a second. Take your time.
>> All right, let's do this.
All right, let me make sure that everybody can hear you.
>> Can Can everybody hear please go? >> Is there
anybody in there? >> Okay, we're back. >> Okay, then
I >> I didn't want you to lose your your oilers and your
chippers. >> That's fine. We've done already very well
today. >> Okay, so let's discuss this then. Yeah, but I
went from your perspective, not like what would be in an arrest
report for what what they would
>> uh No, that's No, it was just for the furler, Riyle,
but I turned it back on >> Say like you as Connor seeing
this, what is the lawful aim that is being accomplished that
would justify this
>> I'm going to give you two.
>> I'm going to give you the way that I think they're going
to write it. I'm going to give you the way that I think that
I'll give you my my perspective.
>> Bro, I think I streamed for like 15 hours yesterday.
Overall, we streamed like all that time I was like live and then
I saw the kick stream was whatever 11 hours and then I looked
at I think the Twitch stream was like an extra 2 hours on top
of that like 2 and a half 3 >> Um, my name's Officer Connor.
I work for the, you know, ICE CVP whatever. I'm duty sworn and
authorized to do XYZ ABC while conducting operations at such
and such uh block. Um, I got sand in my because two shrill 40-year-old
white women were yelling at me and calling me an so as a result
I got mad. Knowing that getting mad and I could use legal pretext
to beat the [__] out of women, I'm going to go ahead
and sight 18 US. This is me off. You know they're not going to
write a report like that. I didn't even want you to do this officer.
>> I got mad and they got in my vagina. Hold on. I'm being
serious with you. This is what I'm trying to be serious. No,
hold on. You're misunderstanding my intent. My intent is to deride
the officer. My intent is not to deride you. I'm criticizing
the officer by saying how I would write it if I was me. >> Oh,
if you were you, you would say it's
>> Well, well, I do think it's unreasonable, but I think
that reasonability is a flexible concept, right? Obviously, particularly
when it comes to law. >> Wait, if you think it's unreasonable,
why is it justified? Cuz >> I'm 6'4 and 230 lb. No, no,
no, no, no.
When I say reasonable, I mean objectively unreasonable, not to
Conor. I mean under the >> Well, then you're asking me
for a different thing. Can I I told you I was going to give you
two things. Can I give you two things? >> Don't give me
the two things >> because I'm trying to What you're What
you're misunderstanding is you think that I'm meaning I'm meaning
in order to detract from the conversation. >> I didn't
understand. I thought you were >> So I I think what nobody
understands is you're saying like it's possible for them to argue
this, but nobody is arguing against you there. And I'm wondering
why you're saying anything can be anything is what you just said.
Anything can be anything. Anything can be anything. It's like,
okay, like you're you're basically giving me nothing. You're
giving me nothing to grapple with or talk about. So, what is
the purpose of the thing you're saying? Could the ICE agents
lie on a report and say that they felt like some there there's
some reason here, right? That isn't just, you know, I was abducted
by aliens and then when I came back down from my alien abduction,
I was like a little, you know, I was feeling hungry, so I punched
this woman in the face. It's like, yeah, they're not going to
write that, but could they come up with something here? This
woman was um interfering with law enforcement operations. Could
they just lie and say that? Yes. Okay. Now, what have we proven?
What What does that serve? How does that serve you in the argument?
Yes, they could lie about that in a police report. They could
write a police report that says a thing that, you know, some
fairly politically motivated people could try to defend or try
to talk about, but we can all see essentially like 90% of the
population can see that that's just wrong. You're like totally
embellishing. You're totally making this
But I I just don't understand what what do you gain from it?
That's that's the question. What do you gain from that from proving
that from saying that? I think that's why Pisco is like asking
he's like litigating it with him and it's we all just don't know
what the point is. >> The meme and if you weren't me I
the my meme is to criticize the officer, not criticize our discussion.
So if you will allow me, I'm criticizing the officer. Okay? But
when I'm done criticizing the officer with my meme, I want to
go back to the serious write up because I think the serious write
up is going to be written and I think it's going to be defended
and I think it's going to be successful in his defense. Okay?
So, I'm going to do the meme, but it is going to be funny and
people who aren't seeing next Tuesdays will enjoy it. Got it.
Okay. So, I Officer McFly was at such and such intersection at
such and such time on such and such date when I was confronted
by two women. Well, hold on. I'm trying to meme. Uh, two women
who approached my >> Dude. Dude, I I don't know. This This
is like He must have run out of stories, right? He must have
run out of stories to like totally
derail with. So, now he's coming up with like hypotheticals,
goofy hypotheticals to totally derail with. >> Vehicle.
They forcibly put it in italics, impeded my investigation by
placing themselves around the vehicle at approximate distance
in case we needed to maneuver to apprehend a different subject.
We could not do so with freedom of movement. They entered in
the roadway, which was dangerous, not just to themselves, but
also to any officer who would want the render aid to prevent
them from being hit by oncoming traffic. Okay. As a result of
that, knowing that they're in violation of 18 USC, now I'm doing
kind of the steel man instead of the straw man. >> Yeah,
go for the steelman. >> I'll keep going with the steel
man. Knowing that these women were putting themselves in danger
and also impeding, forcibly impeding, uh, you know, lawful operations
under 18 USC code 111, I decided that I was going to force them
to disperse, which is my officer's discretion. At that point,
I approached said females. I walked over towards them. I gave
them lawful orders to disperse. They refused lawful orders to
disperse. And while we approached the roadway or the end of the
roadway in the parking area, they still refused to leave the
roadway. Once they chose to no longer leave the roadway, I pushed
a woman out of the roadway because while the push may have been,
you know, a use of force or whatever, a pass a use of force to
a passive resistance to force. Um, effectively, I needed to communicate
to these people that they need to exit the roadway and stop impeding
law enforcement operation. Okay, that's where we're at so far.
And if I was writing the report, that would be the steel man.
Do you want to hear the straw man or do you want to move forward?
>> Um, what do you want to do? I I want to just tear that
apart. >> Okay, so I would like to do the straw man real
quick because I think the straw man is probably going to align
with you tearing it apart. Okay, so I officer McDouchag was doing
an ICE operation harassing random Hispanic people in the city
of Minnesota and two white Karens walked up to my car and told
me that I was a piece of and I got off. As a result, knowing
that I could use 18 USC11 as a pretext, I approached said women
in an attempt to with them in order to get them to stop with
me. When they picked me off, I knew that I could use 18 USC11
as a pretext. And when I got near to the side of the road, I
shoved them and peppered them because these people for trying
to [__] with me. >> Yeah. I mean, which of
those stories sounds more correct? Which one of those is actually
going to be successfully defended in a court of law? >> Well,
can you answer mine and then we can get into why I think they
>> absolutely the the straw man, the law enforcement officer
being off, not liking people challenging his authority and using
18 USC 111 as a pretext to beat up people who are talking to
him is 99% more likely. >> Okay, beautiful. I couldn't
have said it better. But now let's deal with like your contention
that even though that's clearly the more grounded story based
on what we've seen so far and again there could be other video
somewhere that would bolster
>> Oh, how would you legally be arguing? Like how would
you how would you talk through this to show that this is clearly
not the case that like what this guy's what's what's in this
guy's mind comes out in the tape which is what >> this
person's impression in mind will likely survive certainly in
a court of >> keep in mind
the >> get some caffeine I'm going to use the bathroom
we can I I might split this in half because it's a little bit
longer so I might split this in half there or thereabouts and
go and do misk covering those docks
I think I'll do both of And then after
right after this, I'll maybe come back and we'll keep watching
this. So, I'll let this play. I'm gonna get some caffeine. I'm
gonna use the bathroom. And then what? I come back. We're switching
up. All right. >> Uh yeah. Yeah. The steel man where he
says, "Oh, I was just doing my job and these women intimidated
me and I was in fear of, you know, forcible threat because they
approached the vehicle and no other protesters did. They're going
to be able to soy the [__] out about Ethan USC 111
and it's probably going to >> Okay, but I want to separate
very clearly. I almost never want to mention what a court is
likely to say again unless it's informing what your opinion of
the law actually is. Like I want >> But now we're jumping
between legal and moral. Moral I object with all this, but legally
I'm trying to tell the audience what they're going to get away
with. >> I don't want to have that conversation.
>> I want to have a conversation informed by the law and
what your idea of the law is, but I don't want to have a conversation
that's like they'll be able to say this to the judge, they'll
be able to say this to the jury, they'll be able to say this
or that because that I think is weasel, right? Because I think
it avoids you having to answer hard questions. That's why I think
that you want that conversation. I think I've answered every
hard question that you've asked so far. Not only that, I think
I'll be answering even harder questions as we continue. But the
reason why I'm bringing up the legality and what cops are capable
of getting away with under the color of law is because there
is broad difference to law enforcement that's based off of law.
And in order to reduce homicides by law enforcement officers,
we're going to have to talk about prescriptions. And some of
the prescriptions that Democrats and liberals have suck
and they're based off of stupid
So, we'll get there when we get there. Uh, but realistically,
um, I gave you the steel man. I gave you the straw man in reference
to the police reporting and we can move to the the next 3 seconds.
Okay. Okay. Wait, wait, no. I want to address this. So, wait.
I haven't had a chance to tear into both. I want to tear into
all of this. And just heads up. Conor supports the British and
the Boston Massacre Mass Logic. It's funny you say this. And
this is You shouldn't say this because the British literally
were defended by John Adams and at least some of them got away
with the massacre. So, uh just just be clear when you're doing
these comparisons to the Boston Massacre, whatever. I'm pretty
sure they found them like most of them not guilty and John Adams,
one of our most important founders, defended [laughter] them.
So, so just to be clear, I'm not trying to say that I think that
this is like that. I don't think it's at all like this. Um but
but just be clear about your comparisons there. Okay, cool. So
addressing the uh quote unquote steel man, I don't think that
there's a basic I think it's part of your steel man is very conclusory.
It's like I felt that they were violating duh and I believe that
they were impeding my duties, but I'm kind of just looking for
the facts and circumstances that would tend to indicate that
there was a triggering violation, but also of course if there's
a violation of that statute, then the action to do is to place
them under arrest. And how does doing this push accomplish